the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free to make a donation or view
additional materials from hundreds of
MIT courses visit MIT opencourseware at
ocw.mit.edu alright so this hour we're
going to talk about simdi programming
would sell first I'll talk a little bit
about what cindy is and then and then
about the facilities that cell and the
compiler provide for programming with
simdi and then some design
considerations that you have to keep in
mind when you're doing things all right
so the situation these days is that most
compute bound applications are running
through a large piece of data and
running the same computations on it over
and over again or rather running the
same computations across all the pieces
of different data and very frequently
there will be no dependence between
iterations when you're going through
this data so that means there's
opportunities for you to data parallel
lies so as an example if we have for
example say we're multiplying a 0 and B
0 to get c 0 and suppose we want to
actually perform this operation across
all the elements of arrays a B and C so
instead of multiplying two elements or
two integers together we're actually
going to be taking two arrays and
element wise multiplying each of the
multiplying multiplying each of the
pairs element wise and writing the
results to a third array so the picture
is going to look something like this and
you would of course represent this using
you know for example for loop now what
we're going to do is instead of let's
see so you can think of this as kind of
an operation that's abstractly operating
on these entire arrays and we're not
going to go quite that far but what
we're going to do is
we're going to think of these operations
as acting on these kind of bundles of
elements so we're going to bundle our
array elements into groups of four and
then each time we're going to take a
group and multiply with another group
using this element wise multiplication
and write the result to this third
bundle okay does that make sense now the
thing about this kind of model is that
cell is going to provide very good
hardware support for something that
looks kind of like this yes I'll get
into this in fact well this is what we
well we'll be talking about the syntax
and meaning of this kind of thing all
right so okay so for this kind of thing
to happen we need the compiler to
support two different things first is we
need to be able to address these kind of
bundles of elements and these are going
to be called vectors and second we need
to be able to perform operations on
these vectors so cell and the XL c
compiler give us support for this and
what they're going to do is provide
first registers which are capable of
holding vectors now normally you think
of a register as holding you know on a
on a 32-bit machine one machine word
will hold you know a 32-bit in for
example what we're going to have on the
cell is these 128 bit registers which
are going to be able to hold for example
for ins right next to each other so
we're going to be able to take kind of
this bundle of in sand operate it
operate on it as a unit and the second
part is we're going to have operations
that act on these vector registers so
the cell is going to support special
assembly instructions and it's going to
be able to interpret those as acting on
particular vectors but also we're going
to have C++ language extensions which
are called intrinsic and those are going
to give us access to these special
assembly instructions but not require us
to you know be poking around in the
assembly all right now
the big draw of this is that these
operations are going to be pretty much
as fast as single operations which means
if we take advantage of them we can make
our code run say four times as fast okay
so how do we kind of refer to these
vectors when we're coding xoc is going
to provide us with these intrinsic and
we have these vector data types and each
one is just going to specify kind of how
to interpret a consecutive group of 128
bits as some sort of vector and you can
have vectors of you know varying element
sizes and varying number of elements so
when you're programming on the pp you or
the SPU you get these four different
kinds of vector data types you can
declare things as for example vector
signed int which is what I mentioned in
the example which is where you have you
know for insects to each other each 32
bits you can also have vectors which
contains 16-bit integers or 8 bit
integers and you can also have vectors
of floating-point inch floating-point
numbers I should mention that all of
these signed integer types also have
unsigned equivalents anyway so you can
just declare these anywhere in your code
and use them as if they were a C++ data
tape alright any questions on the SPU
you also get some additional vector data
types one is vector signed long long
which is 64-bit ins and you can fit two
of those in 128 and you can also fit two
double-precision floating-point numbers
in 128 bits now the the compilers
actually support these types pretty
nicely so not only can you declare
variables of these types pretty much
anywhere in your code you can also
declare you know pointers to these types
and arrays of these types all right and
so they look pretty much like and you
know natural C++ types except that they
translate directly into these particular
types that the hardware supports all
right now in order to manipulate these
actor vector data we're going to have
the we're going to have compiler
extensions called intrinsic which are
going to provide access to the to the
assembly level features that we want
remember we're going to have specific
assembly instructions that correspond to
for example multiplying to two vectors
which contain each for 32-bit integers
and and instead of writing out instead
of you know going to into the assembly
and and actually inserting that
instruction ourselves we just use a
compiler intrinsic inside our C++ code
and what it does is it provides this you
know notation that looks a lot like a
function call but the compiler
automatically translates it into the
correct assembly instruction and again
you don't have to worry about you know
going into the assembly and messing
around with you know this instruction is
supposed to apply to these registers you
don't have to worry about register
allocation at all the compiler just
figures out the right thing for you and
to use these in your SPU program you're
going to want to include SPU intrinsic
CH now what's a little bit confusing is
that you're going to have slightly
different intrinsics available on the pp
you and the SPU because those are
actually going to have different
instruction sets but anyway as an
example you can you can declare to two
variables of type vector signed int and
then you can multiply them using this
intrinsic called SP you add all right
and assign them to a third vector signed
int questions yep what way are the
introduced if you leave you
is it just a student I early the same
set of operations available or they're
actually semantic differences could make
a little header file that masked over
the differences mostly they're going to
be some operations that are only
available on one and not the other but
in general the if you look at the names
if the names correspond and I'll go into
that in a little bit then the they
should perform essentially the same
function there also some name
differences whether really don't need to
be on for instance attractive a shift
CPU i believe is ours SL shift logical
right shift logical left or shipped
arithmetic right sort of things you
would sort of remember on the the SPU
it's the acronym for rotate and the mask
or shift so our OT Katmai are something
like that too so yes there are some
differences that don't need to be there
all right
okay so to to actually create these
vectors there's a couple of different
notations you can use the first is you
can use this thing which looks like a
cast to for example vector signed int so
you do vector signed int in parentheses
and then a list of four integers you
want to fill in and that will you know
create an create an integer vector and
assign it to a you can also I believe
you can also use that notation with just
one integer and it will fill in that
integer in all four positions there's
also an SP you intrinsic called splats
that you can use to basically copy the
same integer to all four components yeah
is that right David with the parenthesis
in the second okay is that xlc like this
notation GCC sometimes likes curly brace
validation instead so it's in both
replies
the work system
okay great thanks all right and after
you've assigned some of these variables
in order to you know get back the pieces
out one way you can do it is to use this
at a union trick where you assign or
rather you allocate something of vector
signed int and then you tell you tell
C++ that it can find you know an array
of integers in the same place and what
that will do is pull out the components
so if you if you define this Union in
this way then you get a type called in
dec and anytime you have an in fact you
can either do dot vector get at the
vector signed in the vector data type or
you can use dot valves to with an array
index get at the components of the
vector alright and you can also use this
intrinsic call it SP you extract to to
pick out the same components xlc
provides a bunch of different vector
operations that that you can use there's
integer operations floating point
operations there are permutation and
formatting operations which you can use
to kind of shuffle data around inside a
vector and there's also load in store
instructions and I believe we have a
reference linked off the course website
if you want to if you want to figure out
more about these I'm only going to touch
on a few of them okay so the the
arithmetic and logical operations like I
said most of these are the same between
the PPU and the SPU there's some that
are named slightly differently and some
that are not available on the PPU so
these are all the things you would
expect add subtract matt is multiply and
then add with three with three arguments
multiply re s for reciprocal you can
also do bitwise and or xor and i believe
there are other logical operations there
too
now the thing is you have to worry about
you know which ppu or SPU instruction
you're using but you usually don't have
to worry about selecting the right the
right vector type the compiler should
figure out you know which vector types
you're using and substitute the
appropriate in assembly instruction that
produces a result of kind of the same
vector type so these all these
operations are what we call generic and
they kind of they kind of stand-in for
all the specific instructions which are
which only apply to a single vector type
that make sense okay so one handy thing
is the is a permutation operation and
this allows you to kind of rearrange the
bytes inside a vector or two vectors
arbitrarily and so the syntax is sp you
shuffle a B which are your source
vectors and pattern which tells you how
to shuffle them and pattern is going to
be interpreted as a vector of sixteen
bytes and each bite is going to tell you
each bite is going to tell the compiler
how to pick out one of these bites in
the result and how the bite is
interpreted is the the low the low four
bits are going to specify you know which
position which position the source is
going to come from and the fourth bit is
going to specify whether you're going to
pull from A or B so as an example here's
the pattern VC and if you look at the
second byte which is one which is 14 in
hex then that means the that means the
destination register is going to contain
the fourth bite or the fourth bite of be
all right so for means you know select
the element numbered four and one means
select from be so that make sense and
this is a very versatile by by putting
in the right by putting in the right
pattern vector you can arrange for all
these bytes to be shuffled around
however you want
pardon pattern is a constant in the
intermediate rather you can you can fill
in the parameter at runtime if that's
what you're asking
can't construct a pattern
yeah okay also useful are these rotation
operations which will let you shift your
vector left or right by some amount now
one thing to be aware of is that on the
SPU you only have these 128 bit
registers so on the PPU you have
different registers which are suitable
for holding different types for example
there's word size registers for holding
ince and the PPU also has these 128 bit
registers but the SPU has nothing else
so that means whenever you're using
whenever you're using scalar types on
the SPU they're all going to be using
these large registers no matter what the
size of the scalar you're using and and
depending on the size of the scalar
you're using it's going to go in a
particular position inside this this
wide register it's called a quad word
register because it's 16 bytes now the
thing to watch out for is that whenever
you load something from memory into
whenever you load a scalar from memory
into one of these registers there's
going to have to be a little extra
processing done in order to shift in
order to possibly shift the scalar into
the right place inside this register and
and furthermore the hardware is always
going to want to grab one of these quad
words all at a time so loading a scalar
is not going to be any cheaper than
loading one of these quadword registers
so when possible you're going to want to
load an entire quadrant word register at
a time and you know if you just need a
part of it just then then you can figure
that out later but you might as well get
the whole thing questions yep so when
you look at your just scalar question so
when you load a scalar value that's not
aligned it's not aligned with the
third preferred position is that does
their overhead associated with that I'm
not sure how much overhead is associated
with that pardon I'd you know line
stealer accepted you can only load
on 16 x boundaries so it's going to load
the load something that includes that
and that's gonna shoot it in the
position so do on a line when it has to
shift the scalar around is that actually
take longer than when in when it's
natural I don't know well what you can
do you can set some flying sex I'll see
you say align all of my scalars
correctly and you know we'll waste 4x
overhead it would even say align my
array had my array elements so that can
have a scalar read that I can load and
it will waste the overheads that
everything in the array is wand so you
can have the compiler trade-off space
versus time for you on some switches I
think okay so we're going to want to
look at the sim application from
recitation to and we want to adapt that
to make use of simdi data types and
intrinsic so what we've done is remember
we had these XYZ XYZ coordinates that we
were manipulating what we're going to do
is we're going to pad each one it was
three words before we're going to Pat
each one so that it fills a quad word
and so for each quad worth of course the
first three words are going to
correspond to the XYZ components and we
can grab those out using spu extract or
some other intrinsic now when we're
doing manipulations with these with
these components for example we wanted
to find the displacement between two
locations and that's just subtracting
two of these coordinates so we can do
that subtraction which before required
three floating-point subtractions we can
replace that with a single simdi
instruction that make sense okay so all
right so all of this most of this has
already been done and we're providing
most of the implementation of this of
the sim of the simdi version of sin and
what we want you to do is download this
download the tarball for this recitation
and then go
in there and what we want you to do is
fill in one of the blanks all right so
there's just one function here that's
been left unemployment 'add and to see
if you know what's going on see if you
can fill in the implementation for this
any questions so this question this
function you want to implement is is
basically going to take a vector float
and if that float contains you know a b
c and d you want to return of you want
to return a vector which each of whose
elements is a plus B plus C plus D
questions
yeah so we're going to go into sim AOS
yeah okay so here's here's one
implementation basically we're going to
just declare another vector float and
and that vector float we're going to
that's basically we're just going to do
these swaps so notice in this one we're
swapping the first and second we're
swapping the first and second words so
that means down here we're going to want
to carry bits four five six seven and
then or bytes four five six seven first
and then x 0 1 2 3 and then over here we
want bites 12 13 14 15 and then eight
nine ten eleven so everyone see what's
going on for the first shovel and then
we're going to just add that to our
original vector to get this and we can
do that again this time now we just want
to swap these two halves so the shuffle
pattern is going to be 8 9 10 11 12 13
14 15 followed by 0 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 make
sense
okay so the way we translated these the
program we just used into simdi was we
used a destructive arrays basically each
of these trucks that we had from our
previous implementation just carried
over and we just put all those into an
array so thus trucks were right next to
each other alternatively we could have
laid out the laid out the data in memory
in a different way and this is called an
array of structs layout instead what we
can do is kind of put all the like
fields next to each other so that we
have for example an array of all the X
components than an array of all the y
components then an array of all the Z
components and when you kind of reorder
this the data this way you get kind of
different ways you can use to process it
so for example now each quad word
instead of containing the data for a
single point is going to take contain
you know the data for the same component
of four consecutive points everyone see
that and actually we can implement the
algorithm from before in this new layout
but we have to be a little bit more
clever in how we're how we're putting
together the elements before we were
able to just kind of subtract each
subtract or multiply the quad words with
it with each other because those would
just correspond to for example
subtracting the coordinates of two
points now this time we have to kind of
do some additional computation in order
to put all the pieces together kind of
the trick behind this this structure of
arrays implementation which all just
sort of gloss over is if we're storing
state 48 objects then we're going to
need eight objects hold up hold up to 24
or rather for each object we need the
position in the velocity and for each of
those we have x y&z so that means to
store state for each object 48 objects
we need 8 times 6 is 48 words and so we
can put those in 12 quad words if we
pack them right and when we do kind of
sim the operations on these
words that we pull out we can get four
pair interactions so suppose this is a
quad word and its content and it
contains data corresponding to elements
a B C and D and over here we have a quad
word containing data corresponding to
elements 1 2 3 and 4 with with some
sympathy operations we can kind of
figure out the pairwise interaction
between objects a and one between B and
to c + 3 + d & 4 but of course we have
to we have to be able to find the
interactions between any pairs not just
these pairs that line up so what we have
to do is rotate the quad word over by
one word and then do the same thing
again we do that four times in all and
then we add up the results so as you can
see this this implementation is a little
bit more involved and kind of less it
maps to the original implementation kind
of less directly on the other hand it
does give us a really dramatic speed up
kind of because we're using more of the
vector words notice that in the in the
first packing we had we had XY and Z and
then the fourth blank was unused anyway
this time the structure of a race
implementation is actually seven and a
half times faster than the array of
structures implementation so choosing
this data layout correctly can actually
be you know one of the really big
determinants of how your program
performs or is it not comparable
um let's see David do you remember okay
so no that was just on the pp you
ok
alright so okay so something like 400
for the double buffered one and 300 for
array of strokes okay one other thing to
worry about is when you're dealing with
these when you're dealing with these
simdi instructions you want to make sure
that all your data are aligned correctly
in memory and like I said before when
you're pulling things in from memory you
want to make sure that whatever you're
pulling in is going to be aligned on a
quad word boundary and you can use the
aligned compiler directive to tell the
compiler you know I want this piece of
data aligned at a particular place and
if you do that on all your arrays for
example and make sure that your array
the array elements are going to fit
neatly into into quad words then you
should be okay and again like I said
before you also want to transfer only
multiples of 16 bytes on on the on the
load and store and so when you're when
you're doing processing it made help it
may help you if you actually pad the end
of your the pad the end of your arrays
to so that they fill out a multiple of
16 bytes because it's easier to just do
that processing with the simdi
instruction rather than you know just
have a one or two elements hanging off
and and have to worry about those yep
password
figuring out where there's something
cause ileus or not so you might make
enquiry
I certain cases where you can board
using pointer
okay dude are there keywords like to
restrict keyword or something that says
these are unalienable Jesus it doesn't
really strike too restrictive Kathy
whatever it is so so there are pragmas
or little penis doesn't pilot says
passing things about pointers holder but
treat these things is fun line
Hungarians for your passing in arrays
you can say a few words of restrict
which means it's not you can treat us
trumpet figure consumer meaning
relaxation no other references so the
same data right there now if nothing
else whatever nothing else for point to
leave data that you've got the
restrictor pointed to it restricted to
being pointed to provide this particular
pointers
spits not having to the local scope its
global like it so that's its local to a
function where you
qasim to say we function food and a
non-friend or you say restrict pay I see
within that functional structure hole
alright so one last thing that I that I
should mention I haven't really let on
but but compilers can actually generate
some of these simdi instructions by
themselves if you declare your types to
be vector and then you use just regular
operations apparently GCC and XL CES
will will substitute the correct
intrinsic for you of course that doesn't
get you all the operations which are
available with intrinsic but anyway
automatically automatically simdi izing
your your code is something that's
really worth looking into as we saw it
can give you a great performance
improvement and the thing is that
compilers are still not very good at to
kind of automatically doing this
transformation so unlike instruction
scheduling where you know if you pass in
05 your compiler will do a much better
job than you would have time to do this
is something that you should probably
you know reserve some time for all right
that's all if you have any questions you
can stick around and I'll try and help
you